[Music]
randall chamblee golf channel lead
studio analyst nbc sports providing
comprehensive coverage of the ryder cup
from whistling straits you'll see it on
nbc golf channel peacock and it starts
friday morning at 8 eastern on golf
channel brandel justin leonard rich
lerner recapped the action in-depth
analysis live from the ryder cup on golf
channel
brando great to talk to you set the
scene what's the weather going to be
like at whistling straits
well it's going to be windy probably a
little bit chilly i think it's supposed
to warm up a little bit tomorrow but the
weather that the players have been uh
practicing in is going to switch you
know the wins are going to come out of a
different direction but it's going to be
brutal hard golf course hard against
lake michigan and you know it's going to
look like an open championship
when it comes to trying to assess both
of these teams um we used to always look
at the europeans and say they got along
with each other like they they were
friends with each other they would room
with each other and that camaraderie
would play out in the ryder cup is that
still the the case with the european
team and the united states team
yeah i think that's a pretty good
assessment of things i mean it's it's
it's hard it's the hardest puzzle to put
together why the europeans continue to
dominate because almost every single
year they're
they're a pretty big underdog coming in
here in every facet
but i think by and large the difference
is it's not like it doesn't mean
anything to the u.s it does it means a
lot to them you hear them you see them
when they win you see when they lose you
can tell it means a lot to them but as
some europeans have described it to me
it's life and death for the europeans it
means that much to them and yet they
find this perfect harmony between the
intensity and the levity that you need
to play your best golf whereas the
united states they play tight and they
just don't play their best golf there's
several reasons why i think they haven't
been able to
by and large beat europe but that's
that's one small part of it justin
leonard last night on the broadcast said
that when you play on your home turf
it's like one and a half or two points
that that that's the home course
advantage there and he talked about how
you have to win if shane lowry wins that
first match tomorrow morning then you've
cut that lead in half do you agree with
that assessment
yeah if you go back in the world of
ranking era
the home
field home course home country advantage
is a one and a half point
advantage uh
but
you know momentum
comes and goes in this it is very
ephemeral the u.s hasn't lost an opening
session since 2006 and yet they continue
to struggle
by large
i think that
you know the captain needs to impress
upon the players on the u.s side that
they need to play with the same
intensity that they would if they were
10-6 down and singles try to recapture
what they that intensity that they had
going into the in the singles going all
the way back to 1999 i i think they have
gotten up
and i think they've relaxed a little bit
because on paper they're meant to
dominate and they get a little bit of a
lead and europe has been able to flip it
more times than not
what if we traded bryce and dechambeau
to the european team i mean he sounds
french so wouldn't that be a better like
we're trying to create drama tension
good tv
could we trade the shambo to the
european team and who would we get in
return
that's a great question
uh
let's i don't think we'd want to trade i
think he's pretty darn funny no no no we
have to do this oh we have to train yeah
who can we get well if we could get if
we could trade bryson de chambeau for
victor hovla
i think that'd be a that'd be a heck of
a trade you'd trade the longest
driver for maybe the straightest hitter
here victor hovland is a guy i believe
all 12 players on the european side were
asked who they would like to pair with
all 12 or excuse me 11 of them
all said victor hobbler so he's he's
he's that popular uh bryson deschamps
and he's an odd guy i'm not sure many
people want to play with him who plays
golf like him you're going to end up in
spots you've never been in so
i think that'd be a pretty good trade
for the us okay but
you bring up the great point i guess
brooks and bryson are playing nice is
that good for the tour is that only good
for this week this weekend
well i've said this you know you go back
to the beginning of the ryder cup every
single european us team
would have had two players on that team
at least two players on that team that
didn't like each other
this derision on the team between two
players is nothing new social media is
around so we know more about it a little
friction on a team is a good thing in
any group dynamics say a little
friction's good you know it lights
things up get a little spark
i don't think that's going to be the
problem here uh and and yeah to whatever
extent i think they could come together
for the week they have they've bridged
that guy it's not like their mortal
enemies it's not like one or the other
stole the other's wife or girlfriend
here it's like one of them plays golf
and makes it look as difficult as tax
codes and the other one makes it look as
simple as snow falling off a log they're
just two different people
team golf versus individual golf
in how you pair
like like that we talk about chemistry a
lot in sports but but you know trying to
piece it all together it's like jigsaw
puzzles and the pieces you put together
um how delicate is that
well i think
i think you can overthink it like for
example uh
sevi
uh jose mourinho although the most
successful team ever
i don't think you would have ever put
those two together in foursomes they're
both uh they drove it all over the map
both of them neither of them would be a
good foursomes team and you put them
together and you think well they're
going to be a horrendous foursomes team
and they were almost unbeatable i think
the one thing that europe has done is
they they either pair like for like in
other words long hitters with long
hitters or straight hitters with
straight hitters
players that even struggle around the
green with other players that even
struggle around the green or
players from the same country or friends
they don't necessarily rely on metrics
to say well this guy hits it straight
and this guy putts great and you put
those two together it's going to work
out that that almost never works out
like for example you know uh fleetwood
molinari came about likely because those
two guys were in the bahamas having a
couple of pops they got a little
liquored up they called bjorn and said
hey we want to play together put us
together there's no metric there you put
them together they're like they went out
there and they just boat raced everybody
and it's like hey you know why not put
together guys and just laugh and have a
good time together randall chamblee golf
channel the ryder cup you can see it
starting tomorrow morning eight eastern
on golf channel are there side bets
during the ryder cup with
like usa versus european players
i doubt it i doubt it i mean i'm sure
going back
in the days of your maybe
but i but i doubt it wait with phil
mickelson he didn't have any side action
phil maybe is the exception phil might
have some side action right now but i
think
if i'm not mistaken i mean i i think
they get a lot of literature a lot of
emails
about let's not do that that's that's
not good for the game uh so it would be
certainly on the hush hush if they do
uh steve stricker gave an update on
tiger woods um what was your reaction to
that update
i i'm just the first time hearing of it
when when did that happen i thought he
was he uh at the press conference just
talked about tiger's health and you know
the road to recovery and there that he
you know things are promising well i i
certainly didn't hear the specifics of
that maybe i was sitting on the set
getting ready to go and i had chaos in
my ear i i was under the impression that
tiger was going to make some sort of
impression before the week was out via
zoom some sort of conference call
you know we've seen a little bit of
tiger woods here and there but i haven't
really heard
any
any sort of predictions about him coming
back or even the state of
of uh his injury and how it's healed up
i mean we've seen a little bit of him
but but not much
which you know the fact that we haven't
heard much
you know i don't i don't know how to
take that really um i'm guessing his
relationship with stricker
that tiger would probably zoom in
tonight to talk to the team that that's
just a guess
yeah yeah i i i could see that uh and
that'd be good i mean
you know the game misses tiger uh
he's stuck on 82 wins tied with sam
sneed you know does tiger woods have
another miraculous comeback and he's
already given us you can add them up
it's three or four depending upon uh how
you count 2008 us open but uh he's
remade himself i've lost count so maybe
he's got one more in him it would be
it'd be great for golf and and who knows
maybe his presence will be just the
spark that this team needs if i said you
could have a putt to win the pga
championship
or a putt to win the ryder cup
f four foot putt
you're standing over the putt you win a
major you win the ryder
well
cup
think a us player would say the pga
championship a european player would say
well
i think he'd give 50 50. but a number of
european players would say the ryder cup
we had colin montgomery on our set once
i remember it pretty darn clear uh it
was the u.s open 2013 marion it was up
on our set it was nablo up there as well
with me and i asked carl and
if you could trade all of your ryder cup
experiences for one major championship
would you do it and he was like not a
chance not a chance not a million years
would i do that the next day as i was
sitting on the set i'm not going to say
who this person is but a prominent
person in professional golf came up on
our set
veins were popping pointing saying the
next time somebody says something that
poppycock like that on that set you
gotta call him out it's like what are
you talking
and they said the idea that somebody
would trade would wouldn't trade their
ryder cup or would trade their ryder cup
experience or wouldn't trade their ryder
cup experience for a major championship
is preposterous and i thought well that
is the difference between europeans
and americans
europeans it is life or death for them i
had a european say it to me yesterday
it's not that it doesn't matter to the
us it does it's just life or death for
the europeans is how they've described
it
yeah but i i understand that with monty
absolutely from the european side of
this if you i mean they enjoy this more
it means more to them than it does the
united states it just does and i think
because of that yeah the u.s players
would want to win a major where this is
we we want a major that's the feeling
that you would get with the ryder cup
right i mean loads of players have have
won major championships how many have
done what ian poulter's
done
in the ryder cup ian poulter
he's won what three times i think in the
united states or on the pga tour he's
won a fair bit in europe he's he's
under reigns or underrated i would say
uh in that regard but when you look at
what he's done in the ryder cup he's
he's a legend
uh sam torrance never won a major
championship he's a legend colin
montgomery he's he's a legend no doubt
carl montgomery got into the hall of
fame because largely what he meant and
did uh in in the ryder cup he could have
not done any of that won one major
championship and not been in the hall of
fame
um so yes it does mean and jack nicklaus
i think has summed this up pretty well
so has tiger woods look you know by and
large you know the better players on the
u.s side are such colossally good
players with unbelievable records that
there is no career prestige to be gained
from them winning
a series of ryder cups or making the
winning putt it it doesn't really matter
and how they're viewed as players
whereas
lesser careers uh they look at a ryder
cup as a chance to enhance their legacy
and a reputation and it's worked
beautifully for
notably more europeans
great to talk to you keep stirring it up
have fun this weekend we'll be watching
thank you brandel thanks dan always
pleasure that's randall chamblee